-Hello!
-Hi.
-This is a very -- It's been
a very exciting few weeks for me
because I've seen you
a couple of times.
-Yeah.
-I saw you at the Emmys.
You were nominated at the Emmys.
-[ Coughs ] Loser.
-You were a loser.
[ Laughter ]
I'm glad you said it...
-Yes.
-...so I didn't have
to fill everybody in.
[ Laughter ]
But I want to ask,
because I think people are very,
at the Emmys, proper.
And then at parties, people ar
so excited to see Ted Danson
Who were you excited to see?
Were there people --
-Ooh, yeah.
A lot, actually.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Starting with Phoebe.
-Phoebe Waller-Bridge
from "Fleabag."
We actually --
-Whoo!
-Here's a photo of you
meeting her.
We actually --
It was, like, a grab.
Photographic evidence of you
meeting Phoebe Waller-Bridge
-Can I have that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I also want to show how you --
how handsome you are
and how beautiful Mary looked.
-Mary!
Look at my wife.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at her!
-So, Phoebe.
Who else you got?
Who else were
you excited to see?
-Jodie.
-Jodie Comer from "Killing Eve."
-Whew!
-Great.
-Really one of
the best performance I've --
-Really outstanding.
And I will say, the night --
the Emmys itself
can get a little long,
but, genuinely,
the nicest thing about it
is when you get to see
people you've never met.
and go over and genuinely say --
-Summer camp for actors.
-Yeah.
-A little small one.
-And just say,
"You were great in that."
-Yeah.
-And I'm sure you --
-"Schitt's Creek."
-I know you just played off it
a little earlier.
-But "Schitt's Creek"
is genuinely fantastic, yeah
-When CNN makes me
throw things I --
-You like to go
to "Schitt's Creek."
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is bittersweet
that this is the last season
of "The Good Place."
You finished filming
this summer, yeah?
-Yeah.
-Do you feel good?
Are you confident
with how it ended?
-Very, very.
-Yeah.
-And it was so elegant because
usually you get canceled
when you think
you're going back.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's, like, last-minute
You didn't say goodbye.
And it's like, Ugh!"
It's real abrupt.
This was lovely 'cause we knew
the whole time we were shootin
the last season,
we knew it was our last.
because Mike Schur,
creator, who you know,
friend of yours...
-Yes.
-...felt like he had --
will have told his story.
This is how the universe works
maybe?
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-You know, and why pad it?
So. it was really lovely.
We got to be in the moment
enjoying each other,
knowing it was coming to an end.
-You obviously have been a par
of some long-running shows
before that have come to an end.
"Cheers," I guess 11 seasons
I think "Becker" was 6.
-Yeah.
-Did this feel as emotional,
being a shorter season --
-More, more.
Way more.
-More emotional?
-Because prior to this,
prior to meeting my wife, Mary
my way of dealing with endings
was to blow up
my personal life...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-...in such shatters
that I really don't even -
It took me a year or two
to realize "Cheers" was over
-Oh, gotcha.
Nobody...
-No.
-You would just watch reruns
and be like,
"Is that a new episode?"
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, look,
I'm in the 'National Enquirer.'"
[ Laughter ]
-I know that Mike Schur
took this very seriously,
and he took sort of
the philosophy of the show
and the ethics of the show
very serious,
and there would be a professor
in the writers room.
Did you ever spend any tim
with these professors of ethics?
-No, but I have --
I did meet them.
They were --
It was the real deal.
-Yeah.
-Notre Dame has a class
being taught on the ethics a
shown through "The Good Place.
-That's fantastic.
-It really was about --
is about what it is
to be decent,
to live a purposeful life,
that your actions
have consequences.
All really good things
to talk about like this.
-Yeah.
And I would say --
I've heard from a lot of peopl
that their teenage kids
really love the show.
-Yeah.
-Because it talks about
things -- big ideas that I feel,
like, are never given to the
in a digestible way.
-Right.
Because it's wrapped
in a kind of
9-year-old fart sense of humor
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Very helpful.
-Yeah.
-"Cheers" --
all these years later,
"Cheers" never taught
a college class about "Cheers.
Yeah, no, they never --
[ Laughter ]
The ethics of "Cheers"
has never been --
I guess they assume
if you're going to college
you're basically getting
what happens in "Cheers."
-Yes.
That is -- That is "Cheers."
-It was basically, like,
everyone's minor.